the thing is we have multiple goals
right so on the question of stability
democracy is in really good shape in
fact I would say that in the 2000
election cycle one of the things that
really got celebrated when George Bush
and Al Gore were running for president
they get this quirky result everyone's
fighting it out over the hanging chads
in Florida there's all this anxiety
about who won the election for you know
a couple of months and and that we came
out of that process and we ended up with
a president there was no military coup
there was no huge set of demonstrations
and for many people this constituted a
success a win for democracy that we are
a country that is so stable so rule of
law so willing to wait for the process
to work then in fact we can have stable
transitions of leadership even when it
things are looking kind of rough so on
the one hand one might say well
democracy is great we're quite stable
but i think that story of the two
thousand elections could be told another
way as well there was no military coup
there was no outright uprising in the
streets right in other words all the
things that that one might have
celebrated as being about stability one
might also suggest reflects a lack of
robustness a lack of engagement a
willingness to defer to authority and to
rule of law even if in fact it gives us
outcomes that have terrible consequences
for decades to come so I think I think
it does depend on sort of how one might
measure or judge the value or quality of
democracy on the one hand a great deal
of stability on the other hand a great
deal of silence on the part of ordinary
people sort of an inability to really
penetrate the elites and to really
demonstrate and discuss with the central
issues facing sort of ordinary Americans
are